tu peux
[Musique]
sébastien patrick achi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qui se passe je prend le micro
oui ou la micro dams avec l'achat non
parce que ya un retour un peu quelque
chose non parce que je trouve que bon la
caricature tu vois c'est bien je disais
tout à l'heure je suis quand même
capable d'écrire des beaux textes
voilà ça ce n'est pas ça par exemple ce
qu'on fait je trouve que c'est me
réduire à quelque chose qui est un petit
peu trop caricatural dont je sais que la
shdm a tancé match et non j'ai
l'appareil offre et nous a dit tu nous a
dit que pour écrire de belles chansons
voilà donc j'ai préparé je savais que
j'allais venir j'ai préparé un vrai
texte que j'ai écrit sur la prétention
sur la suffisance
est-ce que tu donnes moi donne moi une
note comme ça
je vais essayer de la faire ce que tu
veux est ce que tu veut peut-être la
musique de 2 quand tu pas titre ou non
non non non non s'il te plaît excuse moi
alors c'est un truc sur la sur la
suffisance
il est directeur de si les directeurs de
ça depuis qu'il a réussi il a une tête
comme ça à force de se donner des airs
il est rempli de partout il faut bien
qu'à un moment ils s'étendent et qui
lâche tout faire et quand ils petit
robot
quand il ya la deuxième couplet d'un
dossier complet cela sérieuse parce que
c'est la seule tu as herriot gêne pas de
plus j'habite est devenu ministre
il a une jolie voiture alors que tout le
monde sait bien qu'il est con comme un
oeuf dur quand il passe à la télé il
fait que brasser de l'air salueront de
parler trop menée et ça ressort par
derrière
[Musique]
c'est tout
car tu m'accuses tout sourire
l'antipathie
m
[Applaudissements]
non
ces managers
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'on a tous les parcours au
maximum ce matin qu'on a mené les choses
au point et qu'on sait bien se cacher au
fond du coeur et le talent d'écrire
davantage et je vous donne
l'autorisation de continuer quand la
touche pause 9-9 et le calcul après nice
et mabri merci merci je regarde ce qu'on
voulait c'était la rencontre
il fallait que je me suis senti comme un
cochon dans l'année
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]